police officer for Johns koshima had
been on the run for more than two
decades he's accused of genocide and
conspiracy to commit genocide in what's
considered one of the worst atrocities
in recent memory when more than 800 000
people mostly Tutsis were killed in
1994. Kashima is accused of killing 2002
season Western Rwanda who were hiding in
a Catholic Church he was arrested in
Paul South Africa on Wednesday where
he's been known to have been living for
years here he's facing charges of Fraud
and contravening the Immigration Act
authorities say he lied about his
nationality and used a fake name two
charges of Fraud and three charges of a
transgression of the Immigration Act the
two charges of fraud the first charge is
in 2000 January 2000 when he applied for
Asylum he gave a wrong name and said he
was he was from Burundi and when he
applied for a refugee status in 2004 he
gave the same name and claimed also he's
from Burundi so those are charges one
and two the other three charges three
three four and five relate to him being
in the country illegally the case has
been postponed for further investigation
Kai Shuma could face more charges it's
likely he'll be extradited abroad to
answer to the charges of genocide in
court Kashima said he had nothing to do
with the violence others believe it's a
case of mistaken identity
there is a mistaken identity in not that
is not him but in that the accusations
who are directed to another one who is
the same name but now have been
unto him for for ages and with the
injustice
living in the world we are
it was difficult to say what you are
saying is not me
has been on the U.S state Department's
most wanted list with a five million
dollar reward offered for his arrest the
state says it will oppose bail when
kayashima returns to court in one week
until then he'll remain in custody at a
Cape Town prison while the extradition
process is likely to be a long one
prosecutors say it's the beginning of
justice for victims of crimes against
humanity
Al Jazeera Cape Town